la troisième vague épidémique de l'aco
vide est bel et bien là et avec elle la
lourde logistique dans les hôpitaux
l' agence régionale de santé a même
demandé au chru de tours de reporter
encore plus d'opérations non urgentes
pour permettre un renfort des équipes en
service de réanimation pour les patients
qui attendaient de se faire opérer il
faut s'armer de patience comme cette
famille tourangelle qu'hélène chapelet a
rencontré wallace et un an et demi et
depuis ces trois mois il souffre d'une
hernie dans le bas du ventre
le petit garçon devait se faire opérer
le 30 mars dernier à l'hôpital
clocheville de tours
mais son intervention a été annulé cinq
jours auparavant
[Musique]
depuis aucune information de la part des
services hospitaliers
aucune date n'a encore été fixée pour
une nouvelle intervention chirurgicale
un report difficile à comprendre pour ce
papa qui a lui même été opéré pour le
même motif
il y a quatre mois j'ai eu exactement la
même chose que mon fils c'est air décalé
plusieurs reprises puis après moi je
suis un adulte du coup au niveau de la
douleur ça va mais vu l'accès un bébé ça
nous embête un peu plus on s'est laissé
un petit délai de deux semaines
ce que nous ont mis en attente et si vos
moyens vous partirez dans le privé et
puis au faire tout le nécessaire pour
qu'il se fasse opérer au plus vite que
ce soit à clocheville ou sur les autres
sites du chru de tours 50 % des
interventions non urgentes ont été
reportés le but c'est que les
professionnels soignants et médicaux qui
exercent en bloc puisse être redéployés
dans les services de réanimation qui
traitent les patients qu'aux vide pour
faire face à la pandémie
des renforts en personnel sont également
attendus en provenance du centre
hospitalier d'amboise et du pôle privé
léonard de vinci